Bob the interview today is taking place
in 2015 and I'm wondering in your
studies of film history has the current
landscape of film lost the art of
storytelling and if so how I kind of
feel alone that movies have bifurcated
and gone in two directions certainly big
time productions have gotten way more
interested in crashes and blood spurting
in the end you know phantasmagoria of
all sorts of that don't engage at least
some audiences as all movies did and so
I would have to say if I can judge from
my own viewing habits my own interests
that yeah I do think that movies have
gone someplace else I find myself
gravitating towards watching Barbara
Stanwyck on the screen or watching
tender mercies or watching local hero or
films that are kind of humanely engaging
but these have become yeah you know
minority film so they are special films
that's the kind of value I think of the
independent cinema because corporate
world so far as I can understand not
being in it the corporate world has gone
into the entertainment business and the
entertainment business seems mainly like
the amusement park business to me and so
there's lots of thrills and chills but
as I kind of human experience which I
feel we really want from movies we don't
get it too much or at least I don't get
it too much I go to a movie like you
know oh jeez some it's man or something
you know and doesn't do anything for me
I just watched that stuff and there's
one crash after another one
transformation after another this is no
heart for me but when David Lynch sends
that old geezer on
yeah you know on a lawnmower up to
visitors brother in Northern USA I find
that moving and beautiful and so I do
feel there is a kind of movie which is
still being made which is telling
stories and involved with human struggle
but i must say that we have gotten away
from that pretty commonly maybe it has
to do with the zeitgeist of the time I
do feel we're sort of more dark and
concerned that 911 changed us as a
culture as a country and its people in a
very real way none of us talk about it
very much and none of us can sort of
articulate it in none of us recognize
that others are feeling the same way but
I must say I feel my own life he's got
two parts and there's before nine eleven
and after nine eleven I do think that's
to some extent reflected in the movies
before and after after that time
although that connection is not
necessarily perfect and and direct but
lord knows I just find myself on
probably people from the 60s like me in
general going to the movies per se less
often than I used to watch netflix watch
TV but big budget production films I
rarely find myself going to because I
want something else I got a movie like
lives of others strike me as beautiful
wonderful film and it did win an Academy
Award but it's a typical of what we're
doing right now so I do think that
things have changed and I hope that we
can change them around again one way I
think we can change them around again
that we are change them around is that
all these other little alternative you
know venues for movies are making it
possible for people to do that kind of
thing in my book I wrote a little bit
and then there when I'm touching a
documentary about charlie bit me that
little clip on YouTube which I don't
know if you ever seen it
there's a little boy and his brother
sitting on a couch in England and the
one kid says the other charlie bit me
and ouch it hurts and you think to
yourself what the heck is this you know
charlie bit me when I wrote the book or
when the book came out was about a year
and a half ago when the book came out
there had been 418 million hits there
are now eight hundred and twenty million
hits obviously that little exchange of
two little children sitting on sofa
speaks to people in some fundamental way
that people want and they're not
necessarily getting in big-time movies
so I do think that YouTube and Vimeo and
all these other venues we have for
releasing films is one way that we can
get back to the kind of stuff because
you can do films more cheaply you can do
more intimately and so I'm hoping that
that kind of movie making will
experience Renaissance but lord knows
the other kind of stuff is in control
right now
you